hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to click play quickfire
number one this is a puzzle game click
play quickfire click play quickfire
click play quickfire click play food
click play quick buy oh my god I'm
getting worse click place quick Oh quick
play quickfire click plague ooh
quickfire click play quickfire ah we
play quickfire copán things up in the
middle click place quick for ah I click
play quickfire click play quickfire
click play quickfire I did it
ok now try 10 times in a row I challenge
anyone at home to be able to say that
title 10 times fast you can't do it but
this game is supposed to use your brain
to do a lot of fast paced stuff and I
don't usually like to use my brain it's
reserved for very special tasks because
such as the finding food and seducing
movies but my brains challenging enough
in my day-to-day oh that's it I've got a
great brain a huge brain the best brain
in town you ask anybody they'll say who
has the best brain I do not them me I
say that they don't say that right ok
crank it up oh oh that's adorable uh
stingless trick Oh two differences
uh-huh
ok got it I'm a genius
hold down drag pain larger areas oh it's
disappearing wait ah yeah ok I got it
okay so who three odds oh these yeah got
him
ok we're doing good love is in the air
twos whether given statements true or
false but at the timer run so press a
button to start get ready
No ah yes yeah yes yeah yes
No yeah uh no okay yeah hell yeah this
is adorable uh monster mealtime I don't
know what to do well I didn't seem right
oh okay
ah blood uh that's not right is it
oh no oh that's right it's a robo ah you
would want kids and you need oil oh I'm
an idiot oh and you are brains
wait oh you're on a diet yeah I think
have no idea okay sure oh uh foot
why can't I see this it's what is going
on I'm not seeing anything dear friend
use the cross eye technique that will
highlight the differences immediately I
can't
oh the tongue okay and am i stupid
I'm with the tree the tree in the
background yeah okay I got this
okay so the trick on those is you cross
your eyes and then differences will be
like shimmering in your vision you cross
it so that the same image okay let's eat
three mice - m3 ice three ice cat ice
tea Oh
iced tea iced tea yeah I see oh I knew
that right away
okay ooh three odd spinners okay the
guys spinning the wrong direction are
you you oh man it's like an IQ test I'm
not down for this okay hey shoot all
indicated targets don't shoot all the
other targets mm-hmm no no no no okay
no I I thought that meant an all a the
other air all right hey huh oh-oh-oh
uh-huh oh did it say not to she ah okay
I got this don't shoot okay I got you
all right shoot all right oh god damn it
oh yeah getting it getting up getting it
getting it getting it man they're dead I
did it I killed them do I win a prize am
i doing good okay taking a plunge okay
oh this this oh yeah that felt wrong Oh
something very wrong about that oh god
not again
hargh hargh here again spigen and uragan
got it
see the cross eye technique really works
oh okay
oh uh three chip teeth oh you saw that
you can't hide your disgustingly deform
teeth from me I'll spot it a mile away
what got you okay
cold hard facts choose to whether the
given statement is true or false okay uh
[Music]
yes
wrong yes yes okay I'm doing good
whole lot of stars what are we doing
what are we doing what are we doing I
don't know where we're doing what what
do what huh oh how many yellow ones are
there okay that's easy punk got it
wink and wink okay there we go
I boinked them good man how many of
these things are there ah ah I got it
okay the clues this is an IQ test is
literally an IQ test okay one three so
three total number of triangles so that
one two three four tunnel number of
triangles one two three four five six
seven eight eight one three zero yeah
no damn it oh sorry I had it the wrong
way around this is a I had it right I
just had it there I didn't look at the
symbols close enough because that's what
I fail upon Oh God three eyed trio okay
you you and you okay my god how many of
these are there fix it good okay okay
all right
oh this is a hard one
okay that's probably fine oh no oh no oh
no oh no yeah okay okay
it's Michael Lebowski my my club Wow
scheme what is use is Michael Clouse key
okay okay
good god oh hell yeah I did it i won
with my big brain that I used
effectively and did everything that I
needed to do with the brain I did it and
now I challenge you guys to beat my
score that was actually really fun
because it was so cute I didn't actually
think I'd have to literally think so
much I thought it was gonna be like oh
yeah right hiccup just catch you off
guard like that I thought I'd have to be
doing more you know stupid thinking like
an impossible quiz or something like
that but either way I was a lot of fun
I'll put a link in the description down
below and let me know what your score
was at the end of the quiz who's smarter
than me out there so thanks again
everybody for watching and as always
I'll see you in the next video bye bye